[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Chris manx who joins us
now Chris thanks for joining us um let
me start with Philadelphia here I'm
trying to understand joeel embiid that's
the first person I thought about when
this happened they get expiring
contracts and draft picks Harden didn't
want to be there does Joel embiid want
to be there does he understand what's I
mean he got to look around and go what
what is going on
here I think Joel embiid is probably
relieved to some degree that this is
over before it could get any uglier in
Philadelphia now whether or not Joel
embiid becomes happy almost entirely
depends on what Philadelphia does next
you know they acquired two very
appealing first round picks in this deal
the Clippers pick in 2026 and 2028 when
those picks go on the trade block a lot
of teams going to want them because
nobody has any idea what the Clippers is
going to look like in 26 and 28 nobody
has any idea what the clipers gonna look
like next season so those will be
valuable in a trade and you know two
names I've heard from people around the
league already that Philadelphia will
likely look into Zack LaVine in Chicago
the Bulls we already kind of know
they're going nowhere and the Raptors
have been you know kind of on the
precipice of rebuilding for over a year
now so if the Sixers can go out and get
one of those two players or somebody
else along those lines I think Joel
embiid would be ecstatic I mean he's
already got a really good running mate
in Tyrese Maxi who looks like he's ready
to take that All-Star step this season
if they get one more player and LaVine
and and anobi both do different things
LaVine solves the problem of an extra
score and a ball handler an anobi is
someone they can throw at Phil at
Milwaukee in Boston in the postseason in
terms of wing Defenders I think that
will make Joel embiid happy but right
now I think for Joel embiid it's
probably wait and see what Philadelphia
does next why do the Clippers want James
Harden you know the Clippers have always
wanted James Harden Andor another point
guard they they've not been you know
thrilled with or comfortable I guess the
better word with what they have at the
point guard position they really really
wanted Drew holiday when Drew holiday
became available when he was traded to
Portland the Clippers really wanted him
they had some interest in Malcolm
Brogden but James Harden was the next
guy on that list because he gives them a
little bit of everything you know he can
score he can playmake he's proven he can
succeed on uh quality teams with quality
Stars around him and this really is Dan
a tripling down on on the present like
this Clippers team is all in for this
year they've got Paul George and Kawhi
Leonard who are currently effectively on
expiring contracts both these guys have
player options next year now you get
James Harden who's also on an expiring
contract and you're just kind of pushing
all your chips in the middle and hoping
your starting five which on paper looks
like one of the best starting fives in
all of basketball you know can stay
healthy and give you a chance in the
Western Conference but I'm trying to
understand Harden and that's a dangerous
game to play play that he wants to be
James Harden in the playoffs where you
get to put up 40 points that he doesn't
want to be the guy who gets 11 assists
and 21 points he wants to be more of the
James Harden I get to have fun how are
you going to do that with the
Clippers well I think he can because one
thing In fairness to James Harden when
he got to Philadelphia he changed his
game he became much more facilitator
than he was certainly in Houston and
also Al in Brooklyn he led the league in
assists last season I mean he was a
playmaker for them his disappearance in
the playoffs particularly the last two
games of that Boston series was
certainly alarming and that was probably
the reason you know Philadelphia wasn't
willing to go as high on a contract that
James Harden would have liked in the off
season but I think James Harden if he's
happy which right now currently at you
know 11 o'clock Eastern on a Tuesday he
is if he's happy I think he's going to
be a net plus you know for the Clippers
I I think he's going to find ways to to
uh to facilitate with that Clippers team
and when it comes down to it James
Harden can always go out and get his
shots and one thing to remember too Dan
is you know load management is you know
being discouraged but the Clippers are
still going to load manage I mean Kawhi
Leonard is not going to play 70 games
neither will Paul George so James Harden
is going to get opportunities during the
regular season uh to be the James Harden
of old if he wants to yeah I he was
great during the regular season with the
Sixers with his role and and then Doc
Rivers came on and said look it changed
at the All-Star game when James wasn't
named to the All-Star team that's when
he think that thinks he wanted to go
back and be the James Harden I'm going
to score I want I want my shots
there he's going to want to be the same
player when he goes to the Clippers well
you know Dan the only thing I would add
though is is if James Harden screws this
up I don't know where he plays next
season I don't know what the market is
for James Harden next season I mean the
backdrop of all this drama in
Philadelphia is that James Harden wanted
a multi-year contract like we wouldn't
be sitting here having this conversation
if the Sixers offered like three years
and 100 million the Sixers didn't want
to do that understandably um but James
Harden wants that next deal so if only
for the short term I do think you're
going to get the very best of James
Harden best behavior James Harden I I
think the clippers for one year are
going to benefit from James Harden if
only if only out of self-preservation
you know wanting to be the best version
of himself okay do they does he have a
better chance of winning a title with
the Clippers than he did with the
76ers uh hard to say that's a
no look I I think the Clippers with what
they have again on paper which is not
always just dangerous to do the Clippers
with what they have have a decent shot
to get out of the Western Conference I
mean that starting five is really good
zubach is is a solid Center Terrence man
who the Clippers wouldn't give up is you
know when he gets back on the court is a
versatile guy uh and George and kawhai
you know when they've played together
the numbers are outstanding so if they
can keep them on the floor they've got a
chance to get out of the Western
Conference the problem is you know youve
we got two goliaths right now in the
Eastern Conference not to say there
are't great teams in the west but at the
moment two of the goliaths out there are
Boston and Milwaukee and I I don't know
if Philadelphia with James Harden could
have gotten through either one of those
two teams could the Clippers with James
Harden get through the
West I I can see a I can see more of a
pathway for that than I can see the
Sixers getting through the Celtics are
bucks okay give me the priority list of
best teams in California
who's the best team who's the best team
in in
California uh Golden State's still the
best team I mean what they did to the
Pelicans last night was remarkable I
mean that was without Klay Thompson and
they just stomped on New Orleans at home
that was a game the Pelicans really
wanted to win to show how far they've
come and let me tell you Dan uh I'm not
a huge gambler but I think Chris Paul is
like 1300 to1 to win sixth man I'd throw
a couple bucks on that I would Chris
Paul as a sixth man is excellent I was
looking this up this morning Dan one of
the biggest problems with golden state
the last couple of years has been the
onoff minutes with Steph Curry right
like when Curry's off the floor they've
been terrible when he's on he's been
great right now and it's a small sample
size I grant you right now the onoff
minutes dramatically favor the off for
Steph Curry and I think a big part of
that is because Chris Paul has been
leading that second unit for the last
couple of games you watch that Pelicans
game you know the first stint Chris Paul
had with Steph on the bench when Steph
came back they were plus six like th
this is a huge differenc maker for
Golden State so if again if you want
want to make a couple of bucks whatever
you use whatever your gambling site is
Chris Paul 1300 plus 1300 feels like a
good bet okay so Golden State best team
in the state of California the second
best team
is this is gonna end with me like
dissing Sacramento which I don't want to
do but I I would I'm right there neck
and neck with the Clippers and the
Lakers as number two you know again
injuries are going to decide their fate
this year but I I think both those teams
are are on an even level and Sacramento
to me still a cut below just because I
can't trust them defensively especially
in the playoffs you've got to be you
know a a upper half of the NBA defensive
team to really succeed in the playoffs
and I don't know with this group of guys
which are they're really good I mean
Darren Fox is awesome I've been a fan of
Keegan Murray you know since he was
drafted but they don't have a lot of
plus Defenders there when you don't have
a lot of plus Defenders you're gonna
have trouble winning in the playoffs
great to talk to you as always Chris
safe travels thank you that's uh Chris
manx Sports Illustrated senior writer
he's got a crush on Chris Paul